this was once a home in the village of
umkashiro in Sudan's North Darfur as
Ahmed Adam stands amongst the ruins
where his home once stood he remembers
his life here before being forced out
when the war in Darfur began
people came and raided The Village there
were six cars loaded with guns someone
horses and some were on Camelback they
were from the Arab tribes they killed
the men and bent the village down and
looted property and livestock we had to
escape the mountains to survive
the war started in 2003 with darfuri
tribes rebelling against the government
and accusing it of marginalization the
government responded with airstrikes and
attacks on Villages perceived to be
Allied to the rebels more than 300 000
people were killed and over 2 million
displaced in the years that followed the
U.N described the war as ethnic
cleansing against the tribes here and 20
years on evidence of the war Still
Remains
hundreds of villages across the Darfur
region were burned during the years of
war in what was known as Scorch Earth
policy many of those who were able to
flee are now in camps waiting for the
implementation of a peace agreement
signed in 2020 to be able to return home
the deal sign between the government and
various Rebel groups included
compensation for victims of the war but
some displaced people say other issues
keep them from returning
the people who killed us and burned our
Villages are still out there and they're
still armed we can't leave the camp
without being assaulted by armed men or
running into pickups with loaded guns on
them
local author authorities say Security
will be provided for those wanting to
return
we actually agree in jupa peace
agreement in a in a security protocol
agreement that we say that those
returnees they must go back to their
original Village and we have to
establish the force to carry out the
mission to protect them when they are
going back to their original Village
after 20 years of displacement Ahmed
wants to return home but he needs to be
sure it is safe he doesn't want to be
forced to leave again
and Heber Morgan joins us live now from
the Abu shuk internally displaced
persons camp in North Darfur it appears
HIPAA that the country is still
struggling to move forward 20 years on
why is that
well we've spoken to many displays here
in these camps this Camp right here at
bushok is just one of uh several camps
across the region and North therefore
has the biggest population of displaced
people now we spoke to some of them here
in the camp and some of the displaced
people who have managed to even if
temporarily returned to their Villages
and they say that the security situation
is tough for them and this is why
they're still in camps but they've also
spoken about the economic conditions
about the fact that years or rather two
decades over at this point has
devastated the regional economy and made
made it very hard for them to be able to
pave their way out and rebuild their
lives outside the camp these camps here
in the region are now homes and towns in
the place of The Villages that were
destroyed during the war so for many of
them this is all they know this is the
this is the life that they've been
living for the past 20 years especially
the children and the youth who have been
born in this camps so for many of them
they don't know anything else they don't
know how to to restart their lives
outside these camps especially with many
of them saying that even with the peace
agreement signed more than two years ago
there is still some sort of insecurity
happening and so they're not sure that
they are able to return HEPA Morgan
diverse in North Star for thank you